es una elección colosal la que se abre
en uttar pradesh durará un mes y habrá
siete rondas de votación desde el
comienzo de la pandemia el descontento
crece entre los 200 millones de
habitantes de uttar pradesh uno de los
estados más pobres del país golpeado por
el desempleo y la inflación
los precios están subiendo mucho nos han
hecho muchas promesas pero nunca se
cumplen hay muchos problemas a nivel
local local de sus bocas ciudadanos -en
saben que me inflama meryl vengo de la
clase media estoy esperando que el
gobierno ponga en marcha medidas
concretas para crear empleo y de
incremento según los últimos sondeos él
ve jp el partido nacionalista hindú que
gobierna en la india probablemente
conservará la mayoría en uttar pradesh
para ganarse la confianza de los
votantes promete que al menos un miembro
de cada familia tendrá un empleo y que
la electricidad será gratuita para los
agricultores el voto de los agricultores
es crucial para estas elecciones
regionales porque estuvieron en el
centro de largas protestas contra el
gobierno indio el año pasado durante los
últimos cinco años
y diana ha sido el líder de uttar
pradesh se la acusa de usar la religión
para dividir atrayendo a los votantes
hindúes que representan el 80 por ciento
del electorado en contraste con el 20
por ciento por la comunidad musulmana
yogui aditiana los llamas regularmente
el virus verde trata de doblegar a esta
minoría y formar un bloque con la
mayoría invito estas elecciones
regionales son una prueba para el primer
ministro narendra modi necesita una gran
victoria para consolidar su legitimidad
de cara a las elecciones nacionales de